scoliose et bien si on était en
permanente de la colonne vertébrale
objectif et le déplacement de la pomme
vertébrale et de l'idée la croissance
dans le centre cette action est
applicable sur deux très jeunes il doit
battre alors effectué soit par le
soignant quoi parle étape chez cet
enfant
la déformation position debout et déjà
visibles et le devient encore plus en
position penchée en avant
il apparaît nettement une gibout cité au
niveau lombaire
de face la déformation est peu visible
penché en avant
elle apparaît également au niveau leur
salle
allez tu descends descends bien sur les
talons aux victoires des centres ne sont
jamais pris le meilleur sur mon bien
voici une enfant dont la morphologie
n'est absolument pas atteinte
cependant si on la fait pencher en avant
il apparaît une légère gym aux hits et
dorsale supérieur droit qui disparaît
dès qu'on re même l'enfant en position
verticale
ce camp est un cas de polio débutants
qui piquent keith un traitement pourrait
évoluer d'une façon relativement
les uns restant à l'intérieur même de
l'institut les enfants hospitalisés pour
suivre une scolarité normale
qu'est ce qui permet comme déterminant
quand je dis une belle dune au fait
comment corinne laissant le président
terminant l'article une épée loi annoncé
qu'il injecte dans matthieu l'appui sur
la conduire dans saab la sava qui n'a
pas de tu n'as pas de douleurs sont bien
auditionné de lambert non plus un petit
peu difficile tu fac il pas contents
qu'on leur sert plus et j'en ai beaucoup
tu vas voir ne vais pas gagner mais faut
regarder du temps et puis faire
l'attraction avec on est sûr qu'ils vont
se rendre
chantal vous êtes actuellement
hospitalisé kalou pour traiter votre vie
est très important depuis l'âge de 5 ans
et on a fait ou quatre ans quelles
solutions
et qu'est ce qui vous a ensuite enchaîné
vous savez qu'avec votre news qui
atteint de très important dans un temps
préparation d'israël ont dans un premier
temps pour essayer de votre colonne
l'attraction et puis il ya six
respiratoires pour améliorer la fonction
installons frein intervention pour fils
est dans la meilleure position
l'hospitalisation est pas parce qu enfin
le bol du sang sont systématiques
ce sont des radios ici de février 77 15
me et déjà une scoliose importantes
formations les formations de l'erc amant
en coin et il s'agissait déjà d'une
scoliose qui s'est affirmée quand on l'a
vu ici
tout ça est passé de 65 85 de créer
cette déformation
j 1 et 6 2 transportable et effectuer
une crête vertébrale qui assure
pense-t-on définitivement la correction
de sa déformation la majeure partie des
formations génocidaire qui essaient de
beauce latéral été corrigé par le plein
dans les suites de l'intervention
vous avez vu des cas très grand on a
effectivement des possibilités de
traitement mais au prix d'une
préparation qui souvent longues on prie
la chirurgie et bien sûr et il est
évidemment souhaitable de pouvoir voir
les scolioses à un stade plus précoce
mémoire est plus précoce c'est à dire
savoir les reconnaître
avant que les déformations sous
absolument évident et bien pour ça il ya
des moyens simples des moyens qui
doivent alerter
parce que l'enfant se penche en avant
vous voyez bien la morale c'est aussi là
en ce qui ressort un peu plus d'un côté
que de l'autre celle des poules qui
remonte plus d'un côté que de l'autre
serbe s'en aperçoit région mena
toilettes
pression de l'essai d'une chemise
allocation l'essai d'une robe ou sur la
plage et bien quand vous noté ces petits
signes il ne faut pas hésiter à
consulter car s'il s'agit d'une scoliose
brel qui débute en période de croissance
c'est ce qu'on use pas à crabes et va
s'aggraver et va devenir plus importante
et on a des moyens de l'empêcher salon b
et on a des clients de la stabiliser
norman veulent améliorer dans mon record